And then he slipped on it,
spit it out, and walked away.
That's disgusting.
- Oh, hello. I'm Gav.
- I'm Dan.
Welcome
to "The Super Slow Show."
Dan, I've noticed since we've
been out here in the desert
- we're getting pretty tanned.
- Yeah.
- We're spending too much time
under the sun.
- Absolutely true.
Which is why I've built this
lovely break room for us.
- Lovely. Tremendous.
- You like the finish?
I love the finish.
You did a really
good job with it.
Thanks.
I think the crew's
gonna be jealous.
And we gotta kid it out
with, you know, home theaters
and nice recliners,
couple of X-boxes...
- Yeah, yeah.
- lab coat steamers
and probably a kettle.
- Finish it off?
- I need to get my coffee
that reminds me.
You got the key?
My key's inside.
You didn't lock it.
( sighs )
You know what?
I put in--
remember I put that
that extra way
in the house.
- Like the fail safe in case--
- Oh.
- The way to open the house
in case we locked the keys in.
- Yeah, yeah
What are the chances?
Right when we move in
as well.
( music playing )
- Have to get the locks
changed again.
- I can't believe it.
- Yeah.
- How annoying.
- I never do that.
- I never do that either.
What happened to us?
- Oh, well.
- ( Dan sighs )
Well, luckily I always
carry backups, eh?
Three, two, one!
Dan:
Oh!
- ( distant car alarm blaring )
- May have--
- May have overdone it there.
- I think you set off
someone's car alarm.
That is--
Oh, yeah.
At least the door's open.
A bit excessive I think.
I mean it did the job,
though.
It's true.
You can't argue that it wasn't
a functional fail safe.
- Maybe I can get my coffee.
- Yeah.
It's probably in there.
You bought enough materials to
build another one, didn't you?
Uh, that was it.
Ah.
Thankfully we recorded that
at a thousand frames a second
and 2,000 frames a second
with two Phantom cameras.
- Was handy--
- Was lucky I suppose.
Let's go see
what it looked like.
- Oh!
- Look at the detonation.
Dan:
You see all the dust
on the ground move.
Gav:
You see it already
shook the camera.
The shockwave just rushed
towards the camera.
Dan:
See how far some of that debris
flung there?
- The debris.
- Debris.
Gav: Some of the debris landed
all the way back there.
Must be about a hundred feet
at least.
Oh, you see it blow out
the windows before it goes.
Dan:
Before anything happens
the windows move.
That's so weird.
The overpressure just causes
the whole thing to burst.
It just-- the house just burst.
It just popped essentially.
Gav:
That would be incredibly
painful to be in front of that.
Dan:
Well, yeah.
Your insides would be shook up.
Gav:
What's interesting, though,
is that this places around that
where if you stood you may
not have been hit by anything.
Obviously you'd feel
the pressure wave, but--
Dan: That's a good point.
I supposed if you were--
I reckon there's a spot at
least like two meters away
- where you'd be absolutely--
- And everything would just go
to the side of you.
- Yeah.
- You'd be such a badass
if you stood there.
Gav:
Explosions are always
a lot more interesting
when it's very dusty out
just because
A, the shockwave lifts up a
layer of dust in the ground
and it also sends stuff flying.
- More action.
- Much more action.
- Well, hopefully you--
- Oh, hang on.
- ( Gav sighs )
- I'm sorry!
Where was that?
It was in the
inner pocket of a pocket.
You've always gotta check
your inner inner pocket.
We blew up the house
for nothing.
( sighs )
Well, hopefully you enjoyed
that video.
Feel free to subscribe
to The Slow Mo Guys.
And we'll see you
in the next episode
of "The Super Slow Show."
Not from our house,
though.
The key bit was a bit.
We knew he had it
the whole time.
We were gonna blow it up
all along.
( music playing )
Hello, internet.
Be sure to click here
for the latest updates
- on "The Super Slow Show."
- Yeah, click over there
and you'll actually get
to see Gavin set out
from behind the camera
and get his hands dirty.
It's true actually.
I had to use soap.
Did you get both
of them dirty?
Both hands.
Unbelievable.
Well done.